I'll probably mix up the openings I'll
start with E4 and then
future games like white maybe I'll play
a different first move
oh
what do I want to do
is my opponent gonna play the staff or
Gambit
okay at Stafford Canada time
ah it always feels awkward here like I
sometimes play Knight C3 and try and
transpose into Halloween
but
let me go ahead and play what should be
the refutation Bishop E2
we'll see how prepared my opponent is
yeah there's a small chance my opponent
is watching the Stream
so there's a few moves um the H5 is a
move I like to play nice work area
pairing this as always no mercy
they use actress
so Bishop B6
yeah this is a move I used to play
the idea is to prevent D4 because of
Knight takes E4
um but now each three
and it's hard for black to really
achieve much
probably Knight D2
I like the prospect of Knight C4 or
Knight F3
in the fork or even this move
like D4 E5
so some choices here
I think I'll play this
tracking this
do you play the Evans Gambit sometimes
it's not an opening I played too often
it's an opening I've wanted to study
because it definitely aligns with
my uh my aggressive repertoire for
online rapid Blitz and bullets
I've definitely played a few like
probably a handful of times online
definitely played against it too
yeah in positions like this
um I think it's sometimes a common
mistake for like to Castle too early
and then that could potentially walk
into like a lot of
dangerous attacking ideas
it's one of the ways people go wrong in
the staff room
but it's important to be patient here
and just
play as restrictively as possible
so now I can play
D4 because there's no more pressure
against E4
and then yeah want to develop next maybe
play E5
Bishop E3 looks Pleasant
and this position is not like completely
completely winning but it's just very
very pleasant
for whites
and have some choices what to do
have B4 A4 A5
is one idea
I guess black wants to play some
eventual g-pawn push
which I probably shouldn't be too afraid
of
I do have to figure out what to do here
I could start with a fourth running A5
yeah let's do that let's see what black
does in response
because there's A6 or A5
A6 might allow for like the eventual B5
break
and A5
I'm wondering if it makes sense to go
back
like Knight D2 Knight C4 looks more
attractive now
there's also Rook B1 B4
there's also like Queen D2 Bishop F4 of
a queen D2 there's G5
which not super fond of
yeah I think I'll just go back
it feels like I've lost two Tempe moving
back and forth
but the Knight served its purpose it
made lock Retreat now
um looking to
simplify a little bit
I try and get rid of one of LAX Bishops
oh there's a question why Knight F3 over
D4
I think it was because the pong was
hanging
oh in this position
the other Pawn wasn't hanging
um I guess if I play D4 then the
knight's a bit tied down
but I would be threatening this so maybe
it would lead to some similar type of
position
yeah sometimes in these positions
there's multiple like good ideas and
it's just about choosing one that's the
most logical
overthinking things so Knight C4 take
take
I'll have the bishop pair
getting rid of
most likely black will take
maybe Queen E7 also a possible move
I don't know where I got these quack
do bits just randomly appear in people's
twitch accounts
usually you'll be like you pay for them
like they're one way to support the
streamer
I think there used to be a case where
you can like watch ads and get bits
not sure if that's still the thing
though
Okay so
taking
is a move black is running to take take
and take
so yeah let's start with taking
and then probably Queen C2
Queen C2 is multi-purpose
maybe three reasons to play this
I get off the D file
so I want to discourage C5
I reinforce E4 which could be a Target
and maybe I prepare to queenside Castle
[Music]
but maybe not
so I am calculating B4 takes a five but
then there's B3
not sure about that
I could Castle now is not the
probably not the worst thing ever
I could play B3 and just restricts
be completely restrictive
foreign
let's go
I do have to go and my time's ticking
but I'll also try and stay here
I think I'll play B3
maybe not necessary but
it doesn't really change the dynamic of
the position
puts the ball back in box Court
so
it's like a solid ground stroke from the
Baseline
so I could play Bishop G4 and then F3
I could play Bishop D3
again choices choices
Bishop D3
so from blocks perspective like these
are the the pawn breaks to always keep
in mind
I guess at five
might be coming with F5 E5
I think you could call I think you
cheese Drake quackery
that's a great name
oh
it's a slightly scary move
have to play this
yeah now I really want to get my king to
safety
I'm not enjoying this pin
I think it's still fine though like F5
I can play E5 still
and this is turning into a Blitz game
times about level
oh your name would not have happened
without the duck chess videos
well you're welcome
okay so time to Castle
I mean the dark stories are weak but I
have the dark Square Bishop
I could Castle queenside too
which is maybe even even safer
like Queen here I just defend
yeah so far it's been a pretty classic
strategy against uh the staffer gambits
also thank you adornian gifting 10.
that's so kind
I really appreciate that
if you were a gift to the sub say thank
you to adornian
can use the emotes too
what was I saying
oh yeah sometimes like
the best strategy to play against a
Stafford but also against other gambits
is you just take the pawn and then
be super super solid just play
prophylactically
and
it's a very annoying Style
as a Gambit player to to play against
so yeah let's take the knights
I can see the bishop here but
King will find a a safe place
I will say that black has like played
pretty well for
getting a tough position early on
like I'd imagine that black hasn't made
any
any mistakes other than playing the
Safford gambits
okay so looking to play Rook he1 pretty
soon
I mean from the lock side you want to
look for weaknesses in White's position
or ways to create weaknesses
like the dark square is there
they're usable but I can just kind of
deal with it hello Mr Rosen
hello welcome back to Russman
Vegeta the g-pawn looks backwards but
it's so easy to defend and it's hard to
attack multiple times
okay so rookie two
looks solid
the point of rookie 2 is to double up on
one of the files
I'm not sure which file yet but I'm I'm
staying flexible
another Point might be to bring the
queen to E1
or maybe to E3
so this is nice having
um having the pawn over defended so
Queens no longer tied down
okay I'll play Queen E3
setting up some
potential discovery check
and now Queen F2
now lock either has to allow the queen
trade or retreat
and then maybe I
keep expanding
oh
forgot that was a move wait do I have
if I play E5 there's takes in Bishop
defend or Bishop gets defended
let's move back
opponent offers a draw
I think now I can play F4
and then basically force a queen trade
yeah there's a funny line Queen H2 G4
trapping the queen almost
I guess Queen H2 G4 Queen goes back
but then I can trade and win the G Pawn
should I have taken the draw
I have to show no mercy even if it's
against the staff or gambits
my most loved Gambit
okay time is good position's good
yeah so far it's been very gradual like
just
super solid
like gradually trading and simplifying
so now F5 would be a blunder because
Bishop takes I5 let's not do that
E5 is interesting
I think I'd like to start with King C2
like I'm in no rush
F5 would still be a blunder
so yeah let's
get all the Firepower behind the epon
and now I'm defending the Rooks on
threatening to Fork
I guess it makes sense to trade Rooks
or trade Bishops I should say
simplify further
and now the plans to play F5 Rook F4
go after this Pawn
defend E4 with the King
and The Rook can
probably find a square on G4 if
necessary
B5 is one attempt but I think I'll just
ignore it
yeah so now both pawns are
potentially some issue for black
let's play C4
I have not lost a single Pawn yet
okay so now the goal is to put the Rook
on the C file
oh
opponent has six seconds left
I still want to be like precise I think
I'll play this and then Rook F4
where's my connect eight
oh where's my Pawn mate
okay
I was calculating uh Rook D7 here and
then let's say G5 C5 checkmates
the smiley face mate
anyway that's how to refute the Stafford
Gambit
as much pain as it brings me it also
brings me some Joy
at least when I play the white side